自己要去见众生，
见天地，
要去找到自己该干的事儿，
找到自己喜欢的人，
找到自己喜欢的人际关系，
不要困在这个小小的家庭当中，
原生家庭当中，
不要困在这个私房天地之间，
就算你爸妈一分钱不给你了，
你是不是照样能好好的活着，
就算你爸今天啊，
遗产都被阿姨继承了，
你是不是照样能好好活着，
不要被困在原生家庭的这种关系和利益当中。
你有32岁，
单身，
不婚不育，
你弟妹年入八个，
有一个代步车，
没有房，
但现在我呢，
是住在一个小城市市区附近的一个房子里，
妹妹呢在外地读大学，
我妈癌正刚去世半年，
不到百天，
我爸就开始算先找对象了。
最近从网上认识的一个阿姨，
她刚认了一两个月，
她和我说的是见面了四五次，
但是呢，
这个阿姨催着她要领证儿结婚，
因为我爸她说她肯定是要再找的，
只不过是我妈现在刚走了半年嘛，
他要找是想找一个阿姨带女儿的，
正好是结了婚的，
正好网恋的这个对象是以说她有一个30岁的女儿，
去年刚结婚，
呃，
工作和女婿也比较稳定，
所以我爸相中这个条件了，
但这个阿姨催着我爸要让她领证结婚，
我爸让我过年回去就见康，
他俩应该也睡在我妈的床上了，
反正他们见了好几次了，
我那会儿情绪有点。
激动，
不想见，
因为我妹现在在上专科，
马上就得考试，
她本来是四月份就要考试的，
可是我爸，
但是那个女的在催他，
所以要领这个证儿，
就和我妹说了，
我妹最近学习也学不进去，
情绪也不太稳定。
我父亲的这个状况是她在农村做生意，
有退休金，
市区里面有这一套房，
我妈刚走没多久，
我是比较情绪冷静的和她说的，
要把这个房子过户给我和我妹，
她不同意，
因为她是特别封建的想法，
说我不孝，
她村里有很多平房，
做这个生意，
我具体的财产不清楚，
但是她应该有挺多钱的，
而且我退休金。
这个新阿姨的这个状况是55岁，
但视中我爸和我说她见了几面儿，
具体我不知道，
因为我在市里面工作，
她俩在村里，
而且这个女人她说是在北京打工，
做化妆品的销售的工作，
她说她老公走了8年，
现在反正是在催我爸领结婚证儿，
我爸是态度也比较强硬，
要让我意思就是马上接受她，
过年的时候要回去见她，
我目前的诉求是我如何才能拖着先不让他们领这个证儿，
因为感觉这个岁数我爸是图他的赵国，
这个女的是图我爸的钱，
而且她们是网上认识的，
这个女的她的任何的信息我都不知道，
我想拉长这个战线，
一个是这个，
一个是我爸市区的房子，
他这个市区的房子写的是。
他自己的名字，
我有一个非常恶毒的念头，
非常恶毒的方法，
你伪装成一个别的村儿的男的老头儿，
在网上发帖子说被这个阿姨骗过，
骗了多少钱，
你再把这个帖子转给你爸去看看，
说我得调查一下，
是不是骗了那么多钱，
是不是坑了那么多钱，
是不是把那老头坑残了，
调查完了要是说是冤枉他的，
那这事儿好办，
调查完了之后，
如果说是确实骗了别的老头的钱，
结过好几次婚，
你你就躲被劫呀，
躲过无财害命啊，
躲过这个大郎来趁热把药喝了呀。
我爸她和我说的是这个女人她我公正，
我就你说光做婚前财产公证没有用，
为啥呢？
因为你爸要是砸了的话，
他能继承啊。
举个例子说，
他婚前有一套房值100万，
对，
这100万还是他婚前的财产，
他做不做公证都是婚前的，
不做公证也是婚前的，
但是他一旦领了结婚证，
你爸要哪天爬山摔掉了，
游有溺亡了，
那他可以分遗产的，
那我现在应该怎么做呀？
我想应该可能守住我妈这些遗事，
你不是说就拖一拖吗？
你想先拖一拖吗？
你就说爸，
我确实听到一些风言风语，
我也不是说刻意的想要抹黑这个阿姨啊，
就算咱要接纳阿姨做为家庭成员的话，
咱是不是也应该做一个背景调查呀，
查查他前面那个。
好疼，
怎么死的呀，
查查他跟前面那个谈恋爱的对象，
人家怎么评价他的呀，
看他是一个什么人品啊，
我微姐，
那我可以这段时间跟我爸好好谈，
可以让他房产证上加上我和我妹的名字吗？
如果加上我俩的名字的话，
是不是我们就更加有保障呢？
当然了，
因为加上你们的名字了之后，
他想要卖呀，
想要抵押呀，
想要被骗呀，
难度系数更大了嘛，
因为他现在房产证上是他自己的名字，
我那我记怒他以后他就会马上彻底卖掉。
其实还有一个非常谱的方法，
就是房子呢转到你和你妹妹的名下，
但是呢，
给你的爸爸设一个永久居住权，
这样形成一种三方制衡，
你们一家三口对这个房子都有一定的制衡的权利，
谁都卖不掉，
谁都抵押不掉，
但你爸爸可以一直在这儿住，
住到他去世为止，
这样也省去了将来做遗产变更登记的各种各样的麻烦，
好，
而且胡非姐现在我姥姥姥爷他们现在也是在世的，
所以这个房子的他们也是有权继承的，
如果我姥姥姥爷死了的话，
我姨们也是可以继承的，
是吧？
对呀，
很麻烦，
趁着现在去办过户需要有姥姥姥爷愿意配合的话，
就配合一下，
签个字就办过户了，
但是以我对我爸的了解，
他特别自私，
他想把这个房子应该守住自己的，
他也许会给我，
给我们设置居住权，
但是。
份额大的，
他肯定要收在手里，
这房子现在是你爸妈妈两个名字，
是不是不是只有我爸的名字，
我偷偷拍了照的，
化疗回来，
咱们这些所有的努力都只是隔靴搔痒，
你爸爸如果铁了心的要跟他结婚，
铁了心的要跟他住一块儿，
然后老子来了，
反正也拦不住，
这也是他的自由啊。
对，
我是不反对他再找的，
只不过你的时间有点短，
而且这个阿姨的身份和在北京卖化妆品8年，
我爸几乎没有出过村儿，
所以这个身份的话，
我是想多考察一段时间，
提前把这些财产尽可能的都拿到我和我妹的手里，
那你就跟你爸商量一下呗，
但如果她不同意呢？
不同意你没有办法，
不同意的话，
除非你跟你妹妹作为原告起诉，
你爸爸作为被告来析产，
因为这个房子有一半是遗产吗？
是你妈妈的遗产来析产，
法律上也是可以的，
但是就撕破脸了嘛，
他还有一个问题，
我还能问人，
因为我32岁嘛，
我妹是21岁，
我俩差一轮，
我妈抗癌抗了十多年，
尤其是最后的三四年都是我自己，
我和我爸倒替了去跑医院，
但是我爸妈都一直拼损我妹，
我在医院我又出钱又出力，
但是呢，
最后就是分这个钱的时候，
我妈在医院就说了给我妹30个，
把微信上的剩下的17个给我，
我爸也是答应的，
好好的，
但是在我妈快就是断线之前断签儿的时候，
他骗了我。
我是最后和我妹聊就是套的话才知道的，
我爸说给了我妹15个，
但其实是给了我妹30个，
本来答应好的，
把微信上的剩下的17个给了我，
最后我妈验券钱，
她又开始骗我，
我那会儿特别傻，
我不懂，
他说他以后要养老什么的，
给他留点儿，
他要走了7个，
所以相当于最后我妈给我留了10个，
给我妹留了30个，
但是这些年跑医院跑前跑后的，
我差不多有花了20个，
我心里面就会不平衡，
能理解，
我从来没有想过会对我自己的亲生父母设防，
发现我爸一直从头到尾都在防我，
我就心里面特别不憋屈。
说前面的话，
我刚上班，
手里面只有10万，
妈确诊癌症的时候，
我直接给他转了9万，
我只留了1万的生活费，
但是到头来他一直都在否合我，
还骗我，
那就说明咱们6000元钱呗，
当这事儿啊，
咱回过头来看啊，
你妈妈偏心，
是你妈妈伤害你，
和你妹妹呢，
是没有直接的关系的，
不能把这个恨转嫁到妹妹的身上。
如果假设妹妹对你是很好的，
妹妹对你是贴心的，
遇到困难妹妹是愿意借钱给你的，
那么你和妹妹之间的关系不能因为大人偏心而把恨转移掉，
这样的话，
我本来在这个世界上就是6000元浅，
本来我跟爸妈之间的关系。
不咋地了，
然后我再把爸妈的这种不公平转嫁到妹妹身上的话，
我连姊妹之情也没有了，
那我岂会亏得更大？
但是我薇姐，
我觉得我妹是因为她是既得利益者，
她不说话，
我是没有得到利益者的，
所以我好像我在发风似的，
但是因为从小我妹不管干什么事儿，
她对错都是我错，
我妹她知道她在欺负我，
但是她从来都不说话，
上高中玩到凌晨1点多回家，
我说她，
她不让我说他，
他给我爸妈告专科来骂我，
我问一下，
你妹妹现在是读几年级啊？
他专科准备专接本考试，
他是知道他们在欺负我的，
但他不说话，
而且不是啊，
还告状，
不是这样的姐妹啊，
算账，
我也客观的给你算账，
因为我现在自己也当了妈妈，
从当妈妈的这个角度来算账的话，
可能会考虑到你妹妹年纪小，
她可能还要读大学，
她花的钱更多，
她能独立注意力，
她需要一段时间，
她不是说她读完这个专科，
她就能吃上这碗饭了，
他有可能他考个本科，
他还得读几年的书，
他刚刚出入这个社会，
当妈的人他考虑的是这个问题，
当妈的人在分配资产的时候，
他不是说按照我有100块钱，
一人50块钱这么分，
他有的时候按需求，
就是说按他可能困难一点，
他需要的多一点，
他可能小一点，
他还没长成气候呢，
他可能需要的多一点，
就多给他一点，
是这种情况，
那我以后还要提这个事儿嘛，
最后我拿了10万，
他拿了30万，
如果说你。
困难的时候，
假设你问你妹妹借钱，
你妹妹愿意借给你，
那我觉得这就是我们两姊妹之间的亲缘关系，
如果你妹妹也不愿意借给你，
反正我就承认，
我6000元钱我也不说了，
不说才是证明，
放下了才是证明，
我已经剪断了这些亲情的羁绊，
我变得强大了，
冷漠了，
我说就表明我没放下，
心里面还是处在那样的委屈的弱者的位置，
如果有一天我自己变成一个强者了，
我放下了，
我对什么都放下了，
我就懒得说了，
因为我是体制内工作，
现在还住在我爸这个市区的房子里嘛，
我还遗传我妈的癌症基因，
所以我准备也不结婚，
也不生育，
所以我就感觉特别没有安全感，
就对这个钱就会有欲望，
给我妹30，
给我10，
现在全身上下加起来，
我问一下啊，
我妹拿的多啊，
我问一下你当时给你妈妈花的那些钱，
后来报销回来退给你了吗？
没有，
就每次刚开始的钱都没退给我，
我给我爸转的钱他也没退给我，
我那会儿想的也少，
我现在想起来感觉是他们觉得愧疚我，
我买了一个12万的车，
那这账目不就打平了吗？
但最后这个财产上的分配，
我妹又是我的三倍，
我也没有怪我妹说她没有付出还是怎么样，
毕竟他比我小11岁，
她那会儿在读高中，
我自个儿跑前跑后，
我比他年长10岁，
我上班了，
但最后财产分配，
而且我爸还是欺骗我的方式，
却又要走了。
对，
而且给我了我妹30万，
就和我说15万，
没有在公开的在聊这件事儿，
是以欺骗的方式来和我说的，
所以就整个都是在防备的一个心态，
所以我就特别心寒，
心里面会有委屈，
当然会有委屈，
理解你啊，
那你你想让我问我的问题是事要和我爸提，
这个给了我10，
给了他30，
而且欺骗了我这个事儿吗？
而且他还要走了我的期万，
你先说你想达到的目的是什么？
如果你的目的是想从你爸那多搞点钱的话，
这事儿就不能说，
如果你目的是想要跟他撕破脸的话，
那可以说目的是拿钱人，
那就不能说，
如果你说人真的是人性，
这个东西你要认真琢磨一下，
你想从他手里拿钱，
你说这玩意儿的话，
他只能激起他觉得可能老二更懂事儿的这样一个想法，
不会激起他的愧疚，
你爸要是一个能愧疚的人的话，
他至于说你妈妈尸骨未寒的，
不到百天人家就找新老伴了嘛，
他不会有愧疚心，
就是那这个事儿我就不提了，
因为我妹也还没有工作什么的，
所以我俩没有涉及到钱的问题，
如果后期我和他借钱，
他不借，
那我就和妹妹也断掉，
也可以这么理解，
因为他现在没有花钱的地儿，
而且我丽姐想问一下您，
我思考了一下我爸对我这儿的不安全感，
他怕我不给他养老，
他觉得我不婚不育，
没有女婿也成不了家，
所以给不到他一个支撑，
所以他就一个劲儿的防备我，
但我内心我是不婚不育的，
但我接下来是不是要表现出我想结婚，
想生育，
或者找一个男的和我演一下什么的呀？
不要困在亲情的关系里面，
自己要去见众生，
见天地，
要去找到自己该干的事儿，
找到自己喜欢的人，
找到自己喜欢的人际关系，
不要困在这个小小的家庭当中，
原生家庭当中，
不要困在这个私方天地之间，
就算你爸妈一分钱不给你了，
你是不是照样能好好的活着，
就算你爸今天啊，
遗产都被阿姨继承了，
你是不是照样能好好活着，
不要被困在原生家庭的这种关系和利益当中，
出去见值得见的人，
跟值得这的人在一起聊天，
跟值得的人在一起吃饭，
跟值得的人在一起旅游啊，
好，
我妈走了以后，
我因为我喜欢运动什么的嘛，
就吐目跳舞，
一结交到好多朋友，
反正也特别开心，
你不和我爸联系，
我就感觉我状态特别好，
也不内耗，
那你就从今天就想，
就算你爸今天啊，
所有的财产都被阿姨继承，
或者所有的财产都被你妹妹继承，
请问你会饿死吗？
不会，
我当然可以动情，
因为我能独立的活着呀，
我陪我妈抗癌的过程中，
我也去做了基因检测嘛，
我是遗传我妈的癌症的，
我妈是两个妇科癌症，
但是我又会有点儿担心，
到最后如果全部都断掉的话，
也没有人给我签字儿什么的，
我抗癌的过程中，
也就是我自己有一个法律上的制度，
叫议定监护人制度，
你去深入的了解一下，
什么叫议定监护人制度呢？
监护人啊，
顾名思义就是可以管理你的一些事。
负责人，
比如说父母是孩子的法定的监护人，
如果像我跟你一样，
6000年前这个亲人假设我都信不过的话，
那我就在我的同事、
领导、
朋友、
师兄、
师姐、
老师这些人当中，
我看一看有没有谁是，
我觉得他日子过得挺好，
他比我有钱，
他一点儿不差钱，
他不会存在道德压力，
私藏了我的财产，
形吞了我的财产这种风险的话，
那我就异定监护去公证处，
我就跟他说好，
我俩去公证处，
我就指定你做我的监护人，
一旦我将来有什么情况的话，
你是可以拿着监护人的书可以给我签字的，
但是我现在又感觉我无法信任任何人，
我即使去外面徒步什么的，
但是也都是浅交，
我不敢和任何人深交，
就感觉没有这种能力啊，
那就好好的来姐妹啊，
那就好好的活每一天，
活当下，
此时此刻一呼一吸之间的每一天，
那就是我爸和这个阿姨的事儿，
我就前期把这个房子尽可能的加上我和我妹的名字，
剩下的我也管不了，
也就不多再去干涉了，
是吧？
是的，
那我还需要再去了解一下这个阿姨的家里面的情况什么，
因为我又很怕这个阿姨有高额贷款什么的，
或者让我爸领了证儿以后背上这些就给我增加的麻烦，
跟你是没有关系的啊，
就算他俩欠债了，
我也跟你没关系啊。
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜所有原生家庭不好的姐妹。
都不要困在这个关系里，
不要困在这个亲情里，
因为即便是亲情，
即便是父母，
即便是兄弟姊妹，
但你的世界里也不是全部，
他只是你世界里的一部分，
这一部分不好，
那我就抓紧时间去看看其他的部分，
其他的风景，
他的人际关系，
不要困在这样的原生家庭的，
这种亲情的，
谁偏心了，
谁对不起我了，
不要困在这样的人际关系里，
这个世界上80亿人，
有这么多美好的人你都不认识，
这么多美好的感情你都没有体验过。
抓紧时间，
记得点赞关注哦。